people are figuring out a way to fight
this thing which is great and we're
learning if there's ever been a time in
your life
where the need to want to lose weight
and be in shape
has been the reason to do so if there's
ever been a time you know how people say
hey uncle johnny take care of yourself
hey babe take care of yourself hey bro
you got to kind of lose some of hey dude
you got to kind of like if there's ever
been a time where you got to take your
weight seriously today's the time by the
way yeah you know what's crazy this
message when you give this message
you know who hears it
he
selects the hearing no no the people
that need to hear it they're like can we
change the topic already or something
bro this is like i'm telling you doing
it are like yes exactly
i'm 42 years old phil and we were
talking about it yesterday you were
telling me all this stuff flexibility
i'm feeling at 42. right i'm training
with my guy he says listen if you don't
start at 42 exercise and this thing gets
very hard at 50. and it's going to get
harder and harder and harder health
exercise is very important covet
validated
clean your hands you know that's one
thing fine the other part is your diet
your health absolutely you got you got
to go take care of health a lot of
people just don't look at that so but
you know joe rogan pound more power to
him so happy for the guy very happy if
he's very very necessary today for the
world this is not even like joe's
necessary for the states joe is
necessary for the world because he's
getting everybody to have the tough
conversations so glad the guy is doing
good three days after having covered
yeah yeah
what are you doing
say about him by the way carlos mancia
said great uh he said what i uh uh he
says what he said i got covet uh he says
now they're gonna say yeah what's the
tweet about him you sent it to me it was
hilarious
from rogan
yeah that's he got or something like
that first of all carlos got to get on
joe rogan and get it over with by the
way carlos gomez needs to come on this
show he already has oh you may come back
we're trying to get a date for him to
come on the show come on carlos you will
no but you're definitely right i mean
joe rogan like shout out to you i mean
you know at the end of the day we really
just have to take the aesthetics out of
like working out and just look at just
the health in it in itself i think when
people talk about you know health
they're like oh well you're talking
about a slim waist and this and that
it's like well yeah but
we're really like at the vault i was
talking about how all these
entrepreneurs you know they want to work
hard hard hard push push to make money
for their families god bless them but at
what cost
right you know so then when they get
older they're trying to buy back their
health yeah it's a very powerful message
let's try to figure out a balance but
most importantly right now like with
past saying i mean we're at a great
moment in time where we should be
outside vitamin d we should be getting
healthier you know foods in our bodies
you only get one body
you should really treat it with greater
amount of respect
and this isn't fat shaming or anything
like that but obesity does kill yeah and
right now with kovid we it the stats
show
that if you are overweight you need to
do something about that now that may
come at a you know a price later on if
you ignore it or you could pay for it
now and hire a personal trainer you can
or you can go on google and start
figuring out you know what healthy
methods can i do currently there's so
much information out there so i just
want to encourage more people to
you know just like how you would treat
your business treat your body even
better
you know really mind that body like
figure out like
what you think you're eating probably
isn't healthy well let's change that you
know fast food probably not you know
let's let's learn how to cook again
let's learn how to maybe drink less
alcohol
get proper sleep and when we talk about
recharging our bodies let's recharge
them so then when we are going back like
when you say
you know you're going to run yourself
hard hard hard but then you know how to
recharge so you can do it again majority
of people don't know how to do that so
question for you phil heath seven time
mr olympia
how lucky are we
if there's a scale 100 percent what
percentage of
health and wellness is attributed to
diet versus exercise of working out can
you give those this is very very
interesting because at the vault i had
people tell me what it was
they're like oh it's just uh
eighty percent diet twenty percent
working out and they say okay well if
that's the case then
there would be no gyms like you know you
have to move your body is it 50 50 what
are you saying i mean i think it
definitely depends i would say for the
most part people got to start moving
their bodies so i'm going to go probably
60 40. 64. i'm gonna say 40. no 40 i'm
going to say moving your body 60 diet
40. oh wow uh because just so you know
in the in the bodybuilding world that's
very unconventional to say that
that's what's that's what he's saying
here because most people will say the 80
20 rule right
they move your body it's a very rare you
have to do it like how many people are
actually getting 30 to 45 minutes of
cardiovascular work three to four times
a week just cardio in itself very few
people
how many people are eating like crap all
the time every freaking day so you
definitely have to move your body you
know it you know enhances your lymphatic
drainage we talk about the lymphatic
system we can go into that in another
time but just the levels of inflammation
and due to covid there's this thing
called covid
fatigue
so you know people stressed out all the
time their cortisol levels going through
the roof the inflammation that they
carry you know you start seeing people
that stress you look at their eyes and
you look at their cheeks
you know like they they just look run
down well because they're on the
internet looking at negative stuff so we
talk about positivity more we talk about
loving ourselves more thanking ourselves
more for even standing up for you know
the adverse times
but uh you know i really do believe like
when you talk about faith i think it's
very important that we find something
very positive that we could you know
look at to hold us up when we can't hold
ourselves up so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch or if you want to see the
entire podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]